aquí tenemos un acercamiento a la
superficie del agua y arriba tenemos
aire aire estas son algunas moléculas de
aire pueden ser moléculas de nitrógeno
que están muy separadas aunque en la
realidad se encuentran más separadas que
esto ahora aquí tenemos las moléculas de
agua que ya hemos visto muchas veces
observen que aquí tenemos un átomo de
oxígeno unido a dos átomos de hidrógeno
pero como al oxígeno le gusta acaparar
los electrones eso significa que es más
electro negativo así que tenemos una
carga parcial negativa en esta parte y
una carga parcial positiva en esta parte
de la molécula entonces la atracción que
hay entre las partes parcialmente
positivas y las parcialmente negativas
le otorgan al agua ciertas propiedades
estos son los puentes de hidrógeno
puentes
de hidrógeno y le dan al agua sus
propiedades especiales como por ejemplo
permitir que se encuentre en estado
líquido a la temperatura y presión a
estándar ahora particularmente me
gustaría hablar de la superficie si
analizamos la superficie del agua parece
que está lisa pero si hacemos un
acercamiento a nivel molecular podremos
ver estas moléculas digamos que
aproximadamente ésta es la superficie
del agua y que ocurre en la superficie
bueno todas estas moléculas interactúan
a través de los puentes de hidrógeno por
ejemplo esta molécula formó fuentes de
hidrógeno que la jalan hacia arriba
hacia acá hacia abajo prácticamente la
jalan en todas las direcciones y además
tienen una energía cinética se mueven
los puentes de hidrógeno le dan esa
cohesión y las moléculas se atraen entre
sí pero miren si analizamos las
moléculas que
se encuentran en la superficie lo que
está abajo de ellas las jalan hacia
abajo éstas las jalan hacia los lados y
como no hay nada que las puedan jalar
desde arriba entonces podemos imaginar
que se podrán compactar un poco podrán
estar más cerca unas de otras por eso
podemos decir que hay una llamémosle
fuerza inter molecular más fuerte en la
superficie que a la que existe debajo de
ella eso provoca un fenómeno que se
conoce como tensión superficial aquí
tenemos unos puentes de hidrógeno más
fuertes y como no hay nada que jale las
moléculas hacia arriba porque sólo
tenemos aire entonces pueden compactarse
a eso se le conoce como tensión
superficial
tensión superficial
seguramente ya han visto la atención
superficial
alguna vez en su vida como por ejemplo
en una gota de agua
vamos a ver generalmente una gota de
agua tiene esta forma redonda porque
todas las moléculas de agua en la
superficie de la gota se atraen más
entre ellas que con el aire que la rodea
por eso forman algo como esto y por
ejemplo si han ido a un estanque o
cualquier lugar en el que el agua no se
mueva mucho supongamos que esta es la
superficie del agua seguramente han
visto que los insectos pueden caminar
sobre la superficie del agua no los
puedo dibujar muy bien pero pueden
caminar en la superficie del agua o
también si han intentado poner un clip
en el agua como el clip es más denso que
el agua esperaríamos que el clip se
hundiera pero debido a la tensión
superficial que lo que hace es formar
una especie de película en el agua el
clip no se hunde sino que flota claro
a menos de que lo empujamos un poco con
lo que romperíamos la tensión
superficial ahí si se hundiría qué es lo
que esperábamos desde el principio
porque es más denso y bueno otro ejemplo
sería si tenemos una taza y la llenamos
hasta el borde o quizá un poco más el
agua no se desbordara inmediatamente si
lo hacen con cuidado podrán ver que se
forma una curva eso es porque las
moléculas del agua se atraen más entre
ellas que hacia el aire que las rodea
eso permite que se forme
esta pequeña curva aunque claro si
agregamos más agua en algún momento se
desbordara por la gravedad deshaciendo
la tensión superficial pero bueno esto
se formará en algún momento así que la
tensión superficial se debe a la
cuestión de las moléculas de agua
recuerden la cuestión es cuando las
moléculas se atraen entre ellas
especialmente cuando se atraen más entre
ellas que hacia el aire que las rodea